اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه
ابرز عناوين اليوم
الخارجيتان السعوديه والامريكيه تبلغان
الاطراف السودانيه بوجود انتهاكات لوقف
اطلاق النار
حقيقه المجلس التنسيقي العراقي السعودي
بتقديري رغم انه مر عليه حوادث نائب رئيس
الوزراء العراقي يؤكد على تطابق الرؤى مع
السعوديه حول القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
محكمه لاديل بها تعقد اول جلسه استماع
بحضور المتهمه في مقتل المبتعه السعودي
وليد الغريبي
الرابعه ايضا
رغم اساليبهم الجديده الاجهزه الامنيه في
السعوديه تواصل ملاحقه مروج المخدرات
السعوديه رنيم تفوز بالميداليه الفرنسيه
في بطوله العالم المفتوحه للكيك بوكسينغ
حياكم الله افاد مراسل العربيه بتجدد
الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله شمال الخرطوم
بحري ياتي ذلك بعد ساعات من سماع ذوي
مدفعيه ثقيله ومضادات ارضيه بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في منطقتي بحري
وام درمان فجر اليوم وحول حالات النزوح
التي تشهدها العاصمه الخرطوم اكد مراسل
العربيه باستمرارها بلا توقف رغم الهدنه
المعلنه بين الجانبين كما اشار الى تامين
قاعده وادي سيدنا القريب من الخرطوم
لاستقبال الامدادات الطبيه القديمه جوا
الى السودان وكان مفوض الامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان قد وصف الوضع الراهن في
السودان بانه مفجع
والى غربيه السودان في ولايه وسط دارفور
حيث انقطعت سلاسل الامداد الغذائي تماما
تحديدا عند مدينه ازالنجي كما خرج المشفى
في المدينه عن الخدمه ونقل مراسل العربيه
عن مسؤولين السودانيين ان الاوضاع
الانسانيه وسط الدارفور كارثي حيث تشهد
المنطقه جرائم نهب وقتل واختطاف بالاضافه
الى عدد من القتلب الذي خلفته الاشتباكات
التي تدور في المنطقه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع والتي ادت ايضا الى تزايد
عدد النازحين من المنطقه
[موسيقى]
جددت السعوديه والولايات المتحده التاكيد
على اهميه اتفاق وقف اطلاق نار في السودان
اكدت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان الشعب
السوداني بحاجه ماسه للمساعدات الانسانيه
وعوده الخدمات الاساسيه اوضحت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان المملكه وامريكا رصدتا ان
الطرفين بالسودان لم يلتزم بعدم السعي
وراء مكاسب عسكريه قبل بدء وقف اطلاق
النار اضافه ان المملكه وامريكا ابلغت
الطرفي الصراع في السودان بوجود انتهاكات
لوقف النار كما طالبت السعوديه وامريكا
طرفي الصراع في السودان
بالالتزام باتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
معي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني محمود لعود السيد محمود حياك
الله من الرياض هذه ليست الدعوه الاولى
السعوديه الامريكيه نتمنى طبعا ان تكون
الاخيره
للالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار ما هي احتمالات
التعامل مع هذه الدعوه
طبعا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا انا
اعتقد
الحيض الحل الدبلوماسي والسلمي والسياسي
يعني قصف جهوده في الفتره الماضيه وتوج
يعني هذا الموضوع باتفاق جده او مبادره
جده وكل الدول العالم والمنظمات الاقليميه
منظمه العقاده الاتحاد الافريقي جامعه
الدول العربيه
تعاون الخليجي الدول الاوروبيه الدول
العربيه الدول الافريقيه المجاوره كلها
ايده هذه الاتفاق معناه هو هذا الاتفاق هو
السبيل الوحيد في المقابل لم ينفذ معك
يعني الان انا اعتقد انه داخل السوداني
عليه مسؤوليه كبرى ينفذ هذا
الاتفاق بكل حذافيره ويبدا بالهدنه وانا
اعتقد عليهم كبيره جدا ان والا والا لانهم
لا يريدون مصلحه السودان ومصلحه الشعب
السوداني الان معظم الناس حبيسين في في في
مساكنهم ولا المستشفيات معطله فبالتالي
انا اعتقد انه اذا لم يلتزموا بهذا
الاجراء كما صرح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
لديهم ادوات اخرى الامريكا بالذات للتعامل
مع هذا الرفعود الحديث عن الادوات
الامريكيه الاخرى لكن الموقف العسكري
الميداني اليوم في السودان تحديدا في
العاصمه الخرطوم كيف يرتبط بالاستجابه
بالالتزام من عدمها بهذه الوساطه السعوديه
الامريكيه وانا او هذا الاتفاق الذي وقع
انا انا اشرح لك هذا الموقف بطريقه يعني
يعني مهنيه وليس عسكريه يعني الان موقف
الجيش السوداني هو جيش السوداني لديه
مواقع ثابته يستطيع ان يحدد خطوط تماس من
اجل وقف اطلاق النار يعني المساله مساله
وقفي اطلاق النار يا اخي يعني مساله تحتاج
لضوابط صعبه في ظل ظروف الحاليه الان
المشكله الكبرى التي اعتقد يعني تعيق هذا
التنفيس هذا الاتفاق بشكل يعني
جيد انه قوات الدعم السريع ليس لديها مقر
هي منتشر في الشوارع فمثلا لو لو لو تم
الزام هذه القوات بالخروج من المستشفيات
او المنشات او المواقع الكهربائيه الى اين
سوف تذهب هذا يعني الدعم السريع ليس له
ضمانات من الخروج فبالتالي انا اعتقد هذا
عائق كبير جدا في مساله عدم الالتزام
بالهدنه التي يعني
تتحدث عنها يعني الان يا اخي انا داخل
الاستوديو واسكت الطائره
للجيش السوداني في منطقه يعني مهوله
بالسكان يعني الان هذا يعني انه يعني
الجانبان لا يعيان يعني
بالنداءات هذه النداءات الدبلوماسيه
والانسانيه الان يعني موصل للمفوضيه حقوق
الانسان السامي طلب يعني بان يكون هنالك
يعني يعني امر صارم من من الفريق البرهان
ودلغو للجنود
بان يوقفوا القتال يعني حديث لا لبس فيه
ولكن انا اعتقد انا اعتقد هذه التوجيهات
يعني لم تصل الى ارض الواقع الادوات التي
تحدثت عنها قبل قليل يعني والتي جاءت على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه والخارجيه
الامريكيه ربما ايضا في وقت سابق عبر
المتحدث باسمها
ما الذي يمكن ان يخافه طرفي هذه الازمه من
الادوات الامريكيه التي قد يتم استخدامها
ان لم يستجيبها يعني لوقف اطلاق النار
وطبعا يعني انا اعتقد التدخل قوات اجنبيه
في الوقت الحالي غير يعني وارد ولكن يعني
بحسن يعني بحكم التجارب السابقه اللي نحن
التي عرفناها في الدول التي كانت لديها
مثل هذه السرعات انا اعتقد قد قد تتدخل
امريكا بحكم قوتها وتمنع يعني تحليق
الطيران يمكن هذا واحد من من الادوات من
الادوات التي يعني تمنع من تحرك
او التحرك جوي وكما تعلم يا اخي من ضمن
الممثلين في في في الهدنه اللي هو 12 شخص
كما تعلم موجود السفير الامريكي الذي هو
موجود في الخرطوم السفير الامريكي للخرطوم
والذي موجود من ضمن هذه فانا اعتقد هو سوف
يرفع تقارير ويقدم
مقترحات لحكومته من اجل اتخاذ
اداء من اجل ايضا طبعا الطيران سوف يتاثر
به الجيش السوداني ولكن لا اعلم بالنسبه
بالنسبه للقوات الدعم السريع انا اعتقد
الامر سوف يكون صعب يعني يعني الا ان تكون
هناك تدخل قوات خاصه وتستطيع ان يعني نعم
اشكرك جزيل الشكر لحضورك معي هنا في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي السوداني محمود
العوده شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
يعقد مجلس التنسيق السعودي العراقي غدا
الخميس اجتماعه الخامس في جده غرب
السعوديه لمناقشه خطه العمل المشتركه
للجان المجلس الفرعي يذكر ان مجلس التنسيق
السعودي العراقي تاسس في 2017 بهدف تعزيز
التواصل بين البلدين على المستوى
الاستراتيجي كما يهدف الى اتاحه الفرص
لرجال الاعمال من البلدين للتعرف على
الفرص التجاريه والاستثماريه وتشجيع تبادل
الخبرات الفنيه والتقنيه بين الجهات
المعنيه
اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء العراقي ورئيس مجلس
التنسيق مع السعوديه محمد علي تميم
للعربيه ان العلاقه بين الرياض وبغداد في
افضل حالاتها مؤكدا على الانسجام والتطابق
الرؤى بخصوص الوضع الاقليمي والدولي
انا اعتقد العلاقه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والعراق الان في افضل حالاتها
هناك انسجام وتطابق كبير في الرؤى للوضع
الاقليمي والوضع الدولي ما نريده من
العلاقه ان تستمر وان تكون علاقه تشارك
ومشاركه في الكثير من الملفات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والرؤى لحل الازمات في
المنطقه في ظل عالم تعصف به الازمات كما
كشف محمد علي تميم للعربيه بانه سيتم
الاعلان عن الشركات العراقيه السعوديه
براس مال ثلاثه مليارات دولار من الصندوق
السعودي للتنميه وذلك خلال انعقاد المجلس
التنسيقي السعودي العراقي غدا في جده عمل
المجالس التنسيقيه سواء كانت بين العراق
والسعوديه او بين السعوديه والدول الاخرى
هي لتسريع وتسهيل وتوحيد الراء في الكثير
من القضايا هناك مجموعه من الاتفاقيات
سيتم توقيعها والاتفاق عليها ابرزها هي
الشركه العراقيه السعوديه
مملوكه براس مال حوالي ثلاثه مليار دولار
من الصندوق السعودي للتنميه وهناك ايضا
نيه لتاسيس صندوق عراقي سعودي للاستثمارات
المشتركه
وايضا الاتفاق للاستثمار وتشجيع الاستثمار
في المجال الزراعي والصناعه ايضا وتاسيس
مدينه اقتصاديه
وتجاريه على الحدود بين البلدين
اكد سفير السعوديه لدى العراق عبد العزيز
الشمري في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه على ان
المرحله المقبله ستشهد الكثير من المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين والتي سيتم
الاعلان عنها لاحق
ا العلاقات السعوديه العراقيه في اجمل
حالاتها وفي افضل حالتها
توجيهات القياده الحكيمه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه دعم اخواننا في العراق
في جميع المجالات
وباذن الله ستشهد المرحله القادمه مشاريع
استراتيجيه سيتم الاعلان عنها في حينه بين
البلدين الاجتماع القادم الخامس يعتبر في
عمر مجلس التنسيقي سيشهد انطلاقها حقيقيه
وسيشهد الكثير من النجاحات
من جده ينضم الينا دكتور احسان الشمري
رئيس مركز التفكير السياسي في العراق
دكتور حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
واسال اولا عن المتوقع من هذا الاجتماع
التنسيقي السعودي العراقي في دورته
الخامسه
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه المتوقع من ان
كل ما تم الاتفاق عليه
في على مستوى الاجتماعات الخمس للمجلس
التنسيقي العراقي السعودي ستترجم على ارض
الواقع خصوصا وان هناك عده محفزات تدفعنا
الى هذا الاعتقاد والايمان ومن هذه
العوامل اولا وجود رغبه عراقيه كبيره
بترجمه هذه الاتفاقات السابقه من خلال هذا
الاجتماع الذي سيعقد هذا اولا الامر الاخر
طبيعه ما دفعت به المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبالتحديد سمو ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان حينما اشار بان هناك فرص
استثماريه سعوديه تقدر بمليارات الدولارات
وهذا انا اعتقد انه سيكون ضمن مساحه ومنصه
الاجتماع لكي تترجم بشكل كبير الى ذلك هذا
الاجتماع يمكن ان ينتج ما كان ينتظره
الشعب العراقي والعراق كدوله خصوصا وان
هناك راي كبير رايي سياسي نخبوي من ان
اعتماد المملكه العربيه السعوديه كدوله
ضامنه للعراق وسيادته وايضا تعزيز التكامل
العربي لذلك يعني ما تم الحديث عنه في
المسارات الاقتصاديه الاستثماريه ايجاد
مدينه صناعيه اعفاءات جمرقيه تسهيلات
استثماريه عراقيه لشركات السعوديه انا
اعتقد انها
سيكون مرحب بها في الداخل العراقي خصوصا
انه الى الان ننظر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على انها دوله ارتكاز سياسي
ومالي واقتصادي ويمكن ان تكون رافعه
لازمات العراق في كل المستويات لذلك
الامان معقوده وبشكل كبير جدا على هذا
الاجتماع هناك مصالحات هناك
تطبيع علاقات
ظروف اقليميه ربما هادئه اليوم نتحدث هنا
عن تطويع العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه بعد
الاتفاق والوساطه الصينيه كل هذا كيف
سينعكس على اعمال المجلس
التنسيقيه السعودي العراقي ما الذي يمكن
ايضا ان يضيفه الى اعمال المجلس ايضا كذلك
في اي خطوات كانت متعثره سابقا
انا اتفق معك استاذ نايف من ان القيد
السياسي الذي فرض على الحكومات السابقه
نتيجه
ما مرت به المنطقه او حتى نتيجه الخلافات
ما بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايران
حتى ذلك التدافع ما بين واشنطن وبكين على
مستوى المنطقه كان قد القى بظلاله على
مسار العلاقات على الاقل تقدير الاقتصاديه
لكن الان لا يمكن يعني في ظل هذا
التبريد الذي مضت به المنطقه او خلق حاله
من الاستقرار والشراكه التي تدفع بها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انا اعتقد انه
سيكون محفزا وبالتالي العراق قد يكون لديه
المرونه الكبيره جدا لترجمه هذه الاتفاقات
التي تحدثنا عليه نتحدث عن يعني اتفاقات
منذ انشاء المجلس التنسيقي مرورا باغلب
الحكومات لذلك الان سيكون او يمتلك العراق
مساحه من ترجمه هذه الاتفاقات بدون وجود
الفيتو الخارجي لكن مع ذلك
يعني يبقى التنافس الاقتصادي يعني رغم انه
مقبول الى حد ما لكن على العراق مره اخرى
ان يحدد ان يركز من ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي الاكثر قدره والاقرب على قيام
هذا التكامل الاقتصادي اشكرك جزيره شكر من
جده الدكتور حسين الشمري رئيس مركز
التفكير السياسي في العراق شكرا لك
تعمل السعوديه والعراق على تعزيز العلاقات
الثنائيه فيما بينهما وخصوصا الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه بما يخدم النمو ويدعم الفرص
المشتركه فالتبادل التجاري بين البلدين
سجل 17 مليارا و700 مليون ريال خلال
السنوات الخمس الماضيه القطاع المصرفي
المشترك يعد احد اهم الاعمده الاقتصاديه
التي تدعم الافاق الاستثماريه والعلاقات
التجاريه لكن حضوره ما يزال بالمراحل
الاولى ففي السعوديه حصل المصرف العراقي
للتجاره على رخصه لكنه لم يبدا مزاوله
نشاطه بعد على خلاف المصرف الاهلي العراقي
الذي بدا اعماله في المملكه منذ العام
الماضي بعد حصوله على الرخصه عام 2021
ليكون اول مصرف عراقي هناك طبعا لا شك ان
وجود مصرف عراقي كجزء من القطاع المصرفي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه بيكون لها
دور كبير وفعال في حل معوقات الماليه بين
البلدين وت المصرف نتج عنه توقيع اول
اتفاقيه من نوعها مع بنك التصدير
الاستيراد السعودي لتمويل التجار والشركات
العراقيه في تعاملاتهم التجاريه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وباسعار منافسه
مقارنه بكلف التمويل المعمول بها حاليا في
اوراق الشقيق بالاضافه الى عقد ورش العمل
جنبا الى جنب مع هيئه الصادرات السعوديه
وزاره الاستثمار باتجار الخارجيه لتقريب
القطاع الخاص بين البلدين الشقيقين التوسع
ايضا كان من الجانب السعودي بعد ان حصل
على الموافقه من المركزي العراقي اعلن
البنك العربي الوطني عن نيته المساهمه
بالنسبه 20% في تاسيس بنك العربي العراق
بقيمه 38 مليونا 200 الف دولار مع الشريك
الاستراتيجي البنك العربي الجهود المشتركه
من السعوديه والعراق تؤسس لوضع اللبنه
الاولى لبناء قطاع مصرفي مشترك متين
لتوفير حلول تمويليه تدعم تنميه الصادرات
وتقلل المخاطر خاصه في ظل النمو المتزايد
للتجاره حيث تهدف المملكه لزياده صادراتها
غير النفطيه في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي من
16% الى 50% بحلول عام 2030
الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
قرابه 150 الف سعوديه تعمل في مجالين
العقارات والتشريد
حياكم الله من جديد
تعقد اليوم جلسه الاستماع الاولى للشهود
والمتهمه نيكول روجرز بقتل ممتعه السعودي
ولد الغريبي في فلادلفيا ياتي هذا بعد
تاجيل الجلسه بسبب الادله والمحامين بحسب
والد الغريبي هذا رفضت محكمه في وقت سابق
الافراج المؤقت عن المتهمه الامريكيه ماري
روجرز بكفاله ماليه وطالبت باستمرار
احتجازها لدى الشرطه الى ان يتم محاكمتها
وكان الطالب الغريبي قد قتل على يد روجرز
التي تسكن في احد طوابق منزله بعد اغتياله
وسرقته في يناير الماضي تقرير للشرطه
الامريكيه حينها كشف بان المتهمه ليست
طالبه في الجامعه وانما مدمنه مخدرات
من بلدها بولايه بنسلفانيا الامريكيه
مراسل العربيه حسين الطوت مساء الخير حسين
مرحبا بك معي في نشاه الرابعه من الرياض
بدايه اخر
التطورات حول هذه الجلسه ما الذي يمكن
كذلك ان يحدث فيها جلسه الاستماع الاولى
لهذه القضيه ولماذا اجلت اصلا الى اليوم
تحيه لك انا بالفعل انا امام المحكمه الان
هذه الجلسه هي الجلسه الاولى حيث ستحضر
المتهمه
وايضا شهوده منهم صاحبه المنزل الذي كان
يسكن فيه وليد الغريبه اضافه ربما ايضا
الى جار نيكول الذي سمع الضجيج عندما قتلت
وليد واتصل بصاحبه المنزل عندما اتينا هنا
لاحظنا ايضا وجود تمثيل للقنصليه العامه
السعوديه في نيويورك عبر نائب القنصل
العامه لماذا تاجلت الجلسه بحسب ما فهمنا
ان الاسباب لها علاقه بجمع الادله اضافه
الى امور روتينيه متعلقه بتاثير جائحه
كورونا على سير الاعمال اعمال
الوكالات الحكوميه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا هو السبب الرئيسي حتى
البارحه تحدثت الى والد الطالب وليد
الغريبي وقال لي بانه المحققون كانوا
يجمعون الادله خلال الاشهر الاربعه لذلك
تاجلت الجلسه الاولى من شهر بمعنى ان هناك
ادله جديده ستظهر في هذه الجلسة إلى يومنا
هذا
بالفعل هذا ما اخبرني اياه والد الغريبي
قال ان هناك ادله وهناك امور ستتضح خلال
هذه الجلسه اليوم لان المحققين كانوا
يعملون على مدار الاشهر الاربعه لجمع هذه
الادله سالتها هل كان هناك تعاون بينك
وبينهم التواصل معهم كان صعبا لان ليس
لانه وليد او لانه هذه القضيه نفسها لكن
بسبب كثره الجرائم في مدينه فيلادلفيا هنا
نسبه الجريمه مرتفعه جدا المحققون
يتعاملون مع جرائم بشكل يومي لهذا السبب
ايضا ربما تاخرت الجلسه الاستماع الاولى
الى يومنا هذا سالته ماذا يتوقع
شعرت انه كان مترددا قليلا لا يريد التحدث
قال لننتظر الى يوم غد اي اليوم لنرى ماذا
سيكون هناك ما هي الادله التي سيعلن عنها
المحققون وماذا سيقول شهود العيان الذين
لا يتواجدوا ومنهم كما قلت صاحبه المنزل
حيث كان المغدور يسكن في لدلف
حسين اذا كان هناك نسبه جرائم عاليه في
بلادلفيا وبالتالي هذه القضيه ربما انها
يعني ليست المره الاولى التي تحدث قضيه
مثل هذه في بزلفينيا لان نسبه الجريمه
فيها مرتفعه وبالتالي نسال عن العقوبه
المتوقعه في مثل هذه الحاله
العقوبه هناك بالنسبه يعني اذا كنت تسال
عن عقوبه الاعدام على سبيل المثال هذه
العقوبه تختلف من ولايه الى ولايه هناك 25
ولايه تنفذها و25 ولايه تجرب عقوبه
الاعدام ولايه بنسلفانيا تحديدا اعاده
العمل بعقوبه الاعدام عام 1978 ولكن منذ
ذلك الوقت عام 78 70 وحتى يومنا هذا نفذت
عقوبه الاعدام بثلاثه اشخاص فقط لكي تنفذ
هذه العقوبه يجب ان يكون هناك اثبات على
ان المدعي عليه قد ارتكب جريمه من الدرجه
الاولى الان لكي يثبت ذلك على نيكول هذه
امر يتطلب وقت طويل ربما تستغرق الامور
اكثر من اكثر من سنه ويجب ان يكون هناك
تقديم ادله قاطعه اضافه الى موضوع
الاستئناف ورفض الاستئناف هي ليست مساله
سهله كما ان حاكم الولايه شابيرو كان تعهد
في فبراير الماضي بانه لن يوقع على اي امر
لتنفيذ الاعدام خلال فتره ولايته
بان تنضم في بنسلفانيا الى الولايات
الخمسه والعشرين التي تجرم تنفيذ عقوبه
الاعدام كما قلت هناك في المقابل من يدعو
الى الاستمرار بعقوبه الاعدام بسبب نسبه
الجريمه المرتفعه وهناك من يدعو الى
الغائها مثل حاكم ولايه بنديا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من بلاد فيها بولايه الامريكيه
مراسل العربيه حسين
تواصلوا الجهات الامنيه السعوديه ملاحقه
مروجي المخدرات والاطاحه بهم في مختلف
المناطق والتضييق عليهم كان اخرها عمليات
القبض التي اعلنت عنها الداخليه السعوديه
مقيم من الجنسيه البنجلاديشيه في الخبر
بعد محاولته ترويج 180 جراما من ماده
الشبو المخدر وذلك بعد دفن المواد
وتسليمها عن بعد عبر نظام تحديد المواقع
[موسيقى]
من الرياض يلتحق من المتحدث الرسمي باسم
المديريه العامه لمكافحه المخدرات الرائد
مروان عبد الرحمن الحازمي حياك الله معي
في نشاط الرابع من الرياض كثير من
الفيديوهات تابعناها خلال الفتره الماضيه
يعني منذ ان بدات هذه الحمله على المخدرات
وتبعناها في حساب مكافحه المخدرات وفي
حساب ايضا كذلك ووزاره الداخليه تكلمنا
عنها هل كانت تحدث بذات الكثافه قبل بدايه
هذه الحمله
اهلا وسهلا اخوي نايف امسي عليك وعلى جميع
مشاهديه ومشاهدات قناه العربيه في الحقيقه
جهود وزاره الداخليه بكافه قطاعاتها
الامنيه في حربنا على المخدرات مستمره
بفضل الله عز وجل قامت فرق المديريه
العامه لمكافحه المخدرات من احباط عمليه
لترويج كميه كبيره من ماده الكوكايين
المخدر تجاوزت الخمسه وخمسين كيلو جرام
مخبا في عده منازل وضبط مروجيها في محافظه
جده وفي عمليه اخرى كذلك تم احباطها
لترويج كميه كبيره ايضا من المواد المخدره
قاربت الثمان ملايين و300 الف قرص من
اقراص الانفيتامين المخدر مهربه داخل
شحنات مبيض قهوه وضبط مستقبليها بمنطقه
الرياض وغيرها من الضربات الاستباقيه
القويه والموجعه التي تم تنفيذها من قبل
مكافحه المخدرات وغيرها ايضا من القطاعات
الامنيه المختلفه اها اسال عن
النهج نهجكم في في هذه العمليات في هذه
الملاحقات ايضا او الخطه الاستراتيجيه
التي تتبعونها رائد مروان
في حربنا على المخدرات تكمن في الضربات
الاستباقيه ضد هذه الشبكات الاجراميه
ومتابعه هؤلاء المجرمين والاطاحه به ومنع
تهريب المواد المخدره كذلك
عبر الحدود وذلك باعداد خطط مشتركه مع
الزملاء في المديريه العامه اللي حرس
الحدود وهيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك
وذلك من خلال تمرير المعلومات عن مهربي
هذه المواد وضبط متلقيها بالداخل وكذلك
متابعه مروجين هذه المواد وضبطهم بالجره
المشهود والتي يتم الاعلان عنها بشكل دوري
عبر برنامج بالمرصاد وكما نعمل بشكل دؤوب
في وزاره الداخليه على زياده وعي المجتمع
بشكل عام والاسره بشكل خاص للوقايه من شر
الوقوع في المخدرات هل لديكم تعاون في
المديريه العامه على المستوى الدولي
للاطاحه
بمستخدمين المهربين المروجين ايضا كذلك
صحيح ولله الحمد لمديريه العامه لمكافحه
المخدرات
تعاون كبير بناء ومثمر مع عدد من الاجهزه
النظيره في الدول الشقيقه والصديقه والذي
اثمر بفضل الله عز وجل عن احباط معاونات
عديده لتهريب المواد المخدره سواء داخل
المملكه او حتى خارجها وافشال مخططاتهم
وانشطه هذه شبكات الاجراميه التي تستهدف
امن المملكه وشبابها بالمواد المخدره وهذا
يؤكد الجهود الكبيره والجباره لوزاره
الداخليه في مكافحه هذه السموم على
المستوى الدولي وقد تم الاعلان سابقا عن
الكثير من الضربات الاستباقيه التي تمت
خارج المملكه وكانت اخي نايف بمعلومات
ممرره من المديريه العامه لمكافحه
المخدرات وهذه الجهود تؤكد دور المملكه
الرائد في مجال مكافحه المخدرات والاتجار
الغير مشروع بها اشكرك جزيل الشكر المتحدث
الرسمي باسم المديريه العامه لمكافحه
المخدرات الرائد مروان عبد الرحمن الحازمي
من الرياض شكرا لك
حققت اللاعب السعوديه رنيم الشريف واللاعب
سعود الدوسري
الميداليتين البرونزيتين في اولى
مشاركتهما الدوليه وذلك ضمن مسابقه كاس
العالم المفتوحه للكيك بوكسينغ التي
اختتمت يوم امس في اسطنبول بمشاركته اكثر
من ثلاثه الاف لاعب من 47 دوله وتعد بطوله
انديه العالم المفتوحه من البطولات
الرسميه التي تدرج ضمن تقويم اتحاد
الواكوا السنوي للبطولات
ومعنا من جده لعبت الكيك بوكسينج رنيم
الشريف رنيم مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض
ومبروك سرتي عالميه برونزيه في كاس العالم
ما شاء الله وكيف كانت المشاركه كلمين
عنها اكثر الاجواء اللي كانت فيها الحماس
والله صراحه المشاركه مره كانت حلوه وكانت
اول مره نمثله السعوديه باسمه الاتحاد
السعودي لك
يك بوكس وحققنا ميداليتين طبعا لعبنا مع
اكثر من 3500 شخص ما كان سهل الموضوع لكن
الحمد لله رجعنا ميداليتين
لعبتيها في البطوله يعني المستويات اللي
كانت موجوده الناس من زمان مدربين ناس
كثير موجودين احنا لسه دوبنا جداد في
اللعبه دوبنا بدانا في المنتخب اول مره
نطلع فالحمد لله اني حققنا يعني ميداليه
الاتحاد تقريبا سته شهور
تقريبا سته شهور لكن ساهم معانا
الحمد لله يعني سته شهور حققتوا بذيليتين
انت
ممتاز كلمين عن الاستعداد اللي كان قبل
هذه البطوله كيف استعديتولها
البطوله الاتحاد ما قصر معانا اخذنا معسكر
قبل البطوله في الرياض كان وجابوا لنا
اربعه مدربين للكيك بوكسينج وكانت يعني
صراحه تجربه جميله
وساهموا معانا ودعمونا ماديا ومعنويا
للاتحاد ما قصر يعني الحمد لله وطبعا نحب
نشكر الاستاذ احمد الطويالي
وعلى الاستاذ عبد الملك المزيد ما قصروا
معانا هذا كله الحمد لله وش الفرق يا رنين
بين انك اليوم لاعبة تحت هذا الاتحاد
وفتره ما قبل هذا الاتحاد لما كنت لاعبه
فرديه يعني
لا من اتحاد ولا من احد ما كان عندنا
مدربين لكن الاتحاد هذه مره كان يدور
ورانا كلمونا بالاسم بطولات كانوا معانا
في كل حاجه يعني
[موسيقى]
افضل يعني بالنسبه لك يعني ايوه طبعا يعني
مع دعم الاتحاد يعني نقدر نوصل بطولات وان
شاء الله في بطولات جايه كمان اكثر معاهم
طيب وبعد هذا الميداليه العالميه
البرونزيه وايش عندكم مشاركات
ان شاء الله الشهر الجاي حيطلع بطوله
الاردن حتكون طول عالميه عالميه بيكون في
السعوديه في بطوله كيك بوكس برضه ان شاء
الله والجايات اكثر طبعا ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله يا رب الجاي احسن ان شاء الله
باذن الله ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك من
جده لعبت الكيك بوكسينج رنيم الشريف
مشاركتي في مؤتمر يورماني قال وزير الشؤون
البلديه والقرويه والاسكان في السعوديه
ماجد الحكيل ان تمويلات العقاريه في
المملكه تجاوزت 194 مليار دولار حتى نهايه
الربع الاول من العام الحالي واكد ان
قطاعي العقارات والتشييد والفرع 148 الف
وظيفه للسعوديات
مع نهايه الربع الاول
من 23
تجاوزت تمويلات العقاريه اكثر من 194
مليار دولار بمساهمه في الحراك الاقتصادي
بنسبه 8% في قطاع البناء والتشييد وبنسبه
8.9 للانشطه العقاريه في الناتج المحلي
غير النفطي
ومع نهايه الربع الاول
جذب على القطاع العقاري وقطاع التشييد
حوالي 227 الف وظيفه في الفتره ما بين
2019 الى الربع الاول من عام 23 حيث
يتجاوز عدد القطاعات او عدد وظائف القطاع
عين اكثر من مليونين ونصف وظيفه كما جذب
القطاعين اكثر من 148 الف وظيفه للسعوديات
وبدعم من سمو ولي العهد حفظه الله تم
اضافه اكثر من 100 مليون متر مربع جديده
في الثلاث مدن الرياض وجده والمنطقه
الشرقيه
طابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
الهيئه الملكيه للرياض تعلن افتتاح مدرسه
ريجيت جرامر
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت الهيئه الملكيه
لمدينه الرياض عن افتتاح مدرسه ريجيت
جرامر البريطانيه العريقه في الرياض وذلك
ضمن برنامج استقطاب المدارس العالميه
الهادف لافتتاح مدارس عالميه بالشراكه مع
وزاره التعليم والاستثمار
[موسيقى]
في المدينه المنوره عمل شاب مدني على
اعاده احياء على اعاده احياء عشبه العطره
التي تشتهر فيها المنطقه وحولها الى
منتجات مختلفه الاستخدامات تقدم مع الشاي
والحلويات المدينه التفاصيل برفقه الزميل
سلطان السلام
[موسيقى]
مع ساعات الفجر الاولى يقضي هذا الشاب جل
وقته بمزرعته لجمع عشبه العطره المدينيه
التي حولها من هوايه زراعيه الى منتجات
مختلفه الاستخدامات
زراعيه الى منتجات مختلفه الاستخدامات
[موسيقى]
انا من المتذوقين الشاي ومن محبين اشياء
يعني والتذوق للاشياء العطريه التي تضاف
مع الشاي وعطره هذي احد المنتجات استمتع
بمشروب الشاي مع العطره اما ارتباطها
والله حنا كانت المزارعنا
وقلت خلني اسوي لي موقع واجيب من المنتجات
الشاي النعناع انواع الشاي جميعها
بالاضافه الى المنتجات الحلويات المديريه
[موسيقى]
اخذ احمد الحجوري على عاتقه ابرازا عشبه
العطره للزوار والسياح كمنتج محلي كان قد
غاب لفتره زمنيه طويله في ظل المنتوجات
العطريه الاخرى انا كثير يجوني زوار يعني
يجون لان احنا على درب السنه ما بين الحرم
وقبى ويمرون على عطره ويستغربون في المكان
ده لانه واضح ارث قديم وجميل وخصوا بمشروب
العطره يستمتعون فيه يعني شيء هويه قديمه
جميله وممتعه لهم وانت تعرف السياحه الان
فن تسخر المدينه المنوره بالكثير من
المنتوجات الزراعيه التي تلقى رواجا كبيرا
عند زوار المنطقه وتشهد معدلات زياره
مرتفعه في مواسم العمره والاعياد يعني
بتعكس كثير من تاريخنا
من ستايل من
المنتدى اللي بيقدموه انه بيلامس التاريخ
المدينه احنا متعودين على الشاهي
اللي هو بالنعناع المغربي والنعناع
الحساوي والدوش والاطراء طبعا في انواع
نكهات كثيره تمام في شيء من عنده وفي شيء
[موسيقى]
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
يعد علم الفلك من العلوم الانسانيه
اللصيقه بحياه الانسان اجتماعيا وروحانيا
وعقائديين التفاصيل في تقويم معهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علم الفلك هو العلم الذي يختص بدراسه
الاجرام السماويه وتفسير حركاتها تفسيرا
علميا وهو من العلوم الساميه ليش لانه
القنطره التي توصلنا الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الذين يتفكرون في خلق السماوات
والارض ربنا ما خلقت هذا باطلا سبحانك
فالكون وما يحتويه من نجوم وسدم مختلفه
الابعاد والاحجام تدل على وجود خالق لهذا
الابداع والكون مشحون باسرار اذا حاولت
تفسيرا لها اعياك سيجيب ما في الكون من
اياته عجب عجاب لو ترى
عيناك
[موسيقى]
وعلم الفلك من العلوم الانسانيه اللصيقه
في حياته اجتماعيا وعقائديا وحتى روحانيا
اجتماعيا فنحن لا ناكل ولا نلبس ولا نسكن
الا على مجرياته وعقائديا الانسان القديم
عبد الاجرام السماويه فلما جن عليه الليل
راى كوكبا قال هذا ربي ومعبجي الاسلام جعل
الاجرام السماويه وسيله لغاياته ومن اياته
الليل والنهار والشمس والقمر لا تسجدوا
لشمس ولا للقمر واسجدوا لله الذي خلقهن ان
كنتم اياه تعبدون و روحانيا الكون هو
فضائنا الروحاني انا وانت وهذا الليل
والقمر ندعو صباح كان عنه
[موسيقى]
الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
الخارجيتان السعوديه والامريكيات تبلغني
الاطراف السودانيه بوجود انتهاكات لوقف
اطلاق النار
ان المجلس التنسيقي العراقي السعودي
التقديري رغم انه
مر نائب رئيس الوزراء العراقي يؤكدوا على
تطابق الرؤى مع السعوديه حول القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه
محكمه بلاديلفيا تعقد اول جلسه استماع
بحضور المتهمه في مقتل المبتعه السعودي
وليد الغربي
رغم اساليبهم الجديده الاجهزه الامنيه في
السعوديه تواصل ملاحقه مروجي المخدرات
السعوديه رنيم تفوزوا بالميداليه البروزيه
في بطوله العالم المفتوحه للكيك بوكسينغ
رابعا
الى اللقاء
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات